i reached out to some friends uh one of
them being our next guest
uh actor comedian host extraordinaire
utility dh whatever you want to call him
it is a little difficult because he is a
husky
but
after hearing about his experience as a
husky and
what that means i i give him a little
slack in all this joel mchale joins us
now from his plush palatial estate here
in los angeles good morning joel how are
you
uh can you guys hold on i'm talking to
peyton manning
we've been talking for hours he has
nothing to do
[Laughter]
he just will not i mean once you get him
going that
man
typical peyton yeah just won't stop
talking what's up brother how you doing
this morning i am well i'm here in
studio city and uh it's so great to be
talking to a coug
uh because i always like to talk to the
uneducated it's been a problem for a
long time you know it took me a while i
got a good i got you know i went and got
one of those husky uh educations when i
was in prison so it worked out better
for everybody in this instance
that's great it's uh it's hard to make
fun of wazoo
for all of you listening washington
state university is not the university
of washington
uh eastern washington everyone
everyone's like oh it's still in
washington it's exactly like a different
country but
eastern washington now
is supreme pride i mean primo wine
country now
and wazoo has this great wine program so
it's very hard now to just say you guys
are all just partying and uh don't know
where your pants are because you make
great wine well we we took what we took
what we were best at and that's you know
drinking and turned it into a really
honest to god profession for a lot of
graduates there so you know you know
lemons lemonade type of mentality except
maybe grapes wine there you go who who
would have thought there would be kids
at wazoo with huge plastic cups going
give me some more sangiovese
uh it just it just never never i never
thought it would happen but but here we
are bledsoe bledsoe really turned this
all around drew bledsoe who was uh uh
you know the quarterback ahead of me at
washington state you know when he got
out of the business of football he got
into the wine business and
uh that's i think everybody's kind of
taken taken the lead from that and
followed and followed in his footsteps
so it's very he makes very good wine yes
i'm sure you saw that espn special i
don't know if it was a 34 30 but it was
a special on him and
yeah such a great joke he he was serving
wine to the interview or he just said if
we keep drinking i might start telling
the truth
[Laughter]
great
yeah he yeah he did that with uh jeremy
shap i think with e60 yeah it was a neat
little neat little piece let me let me
say everyone if you haven't listened to
ryan's podcast or the thing the thing
you sent me it is so riveting and so
entertaining and uh
i was listening to it while i was
working out and i had to stop working
out because i was so freaking engaged
i appreciate that pal by the way uh i
was i was going to ask you this question
because
you know
how do you feel when uh when random
friends i'm not going to
share who just randomly send you
screenshots when uh they come upon a
show or a movie that you are in that
they are watching
well
i am like a golden retriever when it
comes to attention
uh that's one of the reasons i got into
the entertainment business because i am
an extreme extrovert
and i know it's really cool to brag
about how introverted you are but i i
receive energy when i'm around people uh
so when people send me those things i
get uh
for the most part i get excited if it's
something that you know i wasn't i was
like uh that wasn't the greatest then
i'd be like okay well maybe they'll come
across something that i'm in that's good
uh but for the most part it's i'm i'm
definitely okay with it so friends out
there just keep sending it
and uh that means i know that when i get
like a screenshot off of uh television
that means i'm being paid for that
that's a good point it's a good point by
the way all you know full full
disclosure here i i sent him a i was
watching ted the original ted the other
night
and all of a sudden joel popped up on my
screen and my wife and i are looking at
it and i screenshotted him in one of the
best lines of the movie was that he had
a picture on his wall with him and tom
skerritt and he just he points that out
to wahlberg's characters like that's me
by the way yes
by the way
that's something that's a great comedy
the lance armstrong testicle that i had
yes the character had
uh
like dipped in gold
[Laughter]
all right let's let's get into your uh
let's get into your hometown team a
little bit right uh
oh
everything's great i really loved well
we're talking about the seahawks what i
was going to say the kraken
yeah no i was going to say if we're
talking about the apple cup uh boy it
was battle of the
interim coaches what
what uh what oh man that was uh that was
real it was it was bound to happen i
don't i don't take a ton of pleasure i
called the game i was in the stadium
that night the first time i'd been back
since i was in the stadium when we won
it in 97 so
you know they had a tough year they had
a real tough year they went out and got
a good head coach i think i think you're
going to be okay with with who they got
we'll see how it turns out but
as for the apple cup uh i didn't even
think about texting you and trying to
get us into some kind of uh
we showed a little bit of wager or
something like that because i know what
a big time griller and uh meat eater you
are as am i that could have been a good
steak night
all right well that let's make a let's
make a date for next year i mean i'll
forget about it but let's say uh no
matter where we are
let's try to uh cook some large dead
pieces of meat and ironically enough we
live like four blocks from each other so
it should be pretty easy
yeah yeah but i've turned my house into
a uh compound oh i'm a pulse now it's a
religious so you're gonna have to join
you're gonna need a rope that's okay
that's okay this last two years i want
to be a part of something anyway
perfect
all right
all right so we're gonna talk about the
seahawks yeah
okay so
they were far from the playoffs right
they had a tough year uh
how do they get back do they change
everything or do they ride it out they
made a big change this week by getting
rid of ken norton their defensive
coordinator but everybody points and
talks about pete carroll and russell
wilson i don't think either are going
anywhere i think they're both there
how do you think this thing shifts and
changes and
is i i just love it when the panic
button i mean it's so i mean seattle
sports does this and i think most sports
but they're as soon like
russell has his finger almost torn off
right so he's out for quite a bit of the
regular season
and we don't do that great but
uh there are obviously insanely good
players we i think we've got all the
parts but people automatically go well
we got to get rid of these people
and i think they're i think they i think
people love talking but
we've only missed the playoffs twice
since pete's been there he's a
tremendous leader as we know and
obviously russell is an incredibly
special quarterback and i i just go i'm
like i keep looking around going like
what's the problem here guys we're going
to be fine and we ended the season
very well
so i think um
i'm not that i'm not worried and i think
with a healthy russell
and with a better i mean we obviously
have some very good defensive players i
think we're fine what do you think yeah
i'm agreeing with you i i think that
this just about shuffling some pieces
around i don't think it's about a
wholesale you know wrap it up and and
try it over again type of mentality you
just can't get rid of you know
generational quarterbacks guys who've
won championships and i think fan bases
and and media members tend to just jump
on something for the immediate
satisfaction of what it is and i think
that that reflects our our whole uh
community at large in in this country
yeah so it it plays out in real time and
when you're doing a radio show like this
and a tv show yeah it makes for a great
fodder and
and and big time fun that's that's why
we talk about it all the time there's
nothing i like better than watching the
post game press conferences and
listening to sports writers trying to
ask the same question 25 different ways
and i it just drives me out of my mind
again if this is my biggest problem then
i have very good problems but
i i yeah it's like you're serving at
dinner well i burned the roll so
everybody go home yeah like
we watched it play out this week with uh
the likes of of the dallas cowboys right
mike mccarthy needs to go we looked at
uh
kyler murray's performance uh and
cliff kingsbury's performance on monday
night and they're like this arizona
cardinals team is is in shambles and
needs to go first time in the playoffs
and forever and
so
it's just reactionary i get it we gotta
talk about it luckily for us we have
some great nfl playoff games this
weekend to get us through the
through all that
yeah i am not i hate when this
like this is my fate one of my favorite
weekends the next two weekends
i hate the time off before the super
bowl the super bowl's
obviously very fun and then there's just
that long
hard
spring and most of the summer while
we're waiting for football to come back
and
i i so like this next this coming
weekend is is one of my favorites yeah
yeah i'm very excited about the oilers
i think a lot of people are i think the
oilers are
the oils are one team i beat as a as a
starter in the nfl so i'm very yeah i'm
very hip to them as well very excited
about the la raiders and the st louis
ranch
what uh uh are you gonna do anything for
super bowl i mean you are uh you pretty
much do everything are you being asked
to do any any things for the super bowl
since it's here in los angeles
uh well it i i have been asked to do a
couple of things and have i i can't
agree i can't do any of them because
i'll be in
uh georgia where i'm working
uh so yes it kills me and i wanted to
let them know let them know that i'm i'm
more than happy to fill in for you
because i think you know you'll take my
kids to the
you'll take my kids to the game yeah of
course i'll take you know i got a
four-year-old you know we can we can
make it work i can i can do that yeah if
you want to trust him with me that's up
to you but i'm more than willing yeah if
you're working down in georgia are are
you going to the game
i have to go speak before the game and
i've never
i've never stuck around for the game
the fact that it's in my hometown
that i'm living in at the time
if i'm if i'm
given some seats where they're
or it's comfortable seating you know i i
might be up to it i just i have a weird
thing about watching football i need to
be like almost alone
in uh with a big tv so i can just see
everything that's going on and and
really
emotionally act out when things are
going on during the game it's just been
a the way i've experienced football my
whole life
all right so if you had your own luxury
box and no one else was in there and all
the lights were off and there was one
monitor you'd be fine i'd be good but i
tell you right if i i'm willing to get a
luxury box and be around people
uh
for this game i'm i'm saying everybody
out there if they're anybody's willing
to give me a luxury box for my family
and my friends for the super bowl we're
willing we'll accept it
i was going to say if you were just
sitting in the regular stands it might
be a little odd there because you would
just be approached by everybody all the
time we went to uh we went to a chargers
game the other day and sat in in some
seats down there and yeah when when i
was leaving
uh it got kind of i think it's i think
more or less it's it's it was for uh
they just want some photos you know and
i i get it i get it but uh
hey buddy
are you a photo taker or do you give
them the moment or do you like i'm a
photo taker i'll do it i feel i it's
humbling it's humbling
i don't know i'm not as recognizable as
let's say you uh and
i i it hasn't it hasn't lost its luster
yet
i think it's incredibly humbling to be
asked to have a picture with me now i
agree you're not as recognizable but
still
it's still cool right dude's just huge
they just go that and i don't realize
how big i am until i see those pictures
all right man we're up against it here i
wanted to thank you personally for for
agreeing to do this uh you're the best
you've been a good friend here
to me in los angeles and i appreciate
you taking the time have a wonderful
new year and uh
and take care of that family well you're
very nice listen to ryan's podcast you
guys it's amazing and uh he's the nicest
and one of the smartest people that has
ever come out of washington state
university which is saying almost
nothing
he tries his best everybody joe mchale
thank you guys thank you joel
go hockey
he had to throw that in there at the end
russell wilson ah what's the wilson alec
go hawks
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here